a human impact is the purpose of a man's
life because someday you will die you
will be dust your money will be fritted
away and taken through taxes and all
kinds of things your property will be
divvied up everything you've cared for
in your life will be taken away the only
thing that endures is the future
Generations who are fundamentally
altered because of your existence on
this planet that is the purpose of a
man's life that is why so many men want
to kill themselves now is because they
find no purpose and no ability to create
human impact
my favorite thing to do is
troll through your Twitter and find
interesting tweets to do with your
history as a psychotherapist as a
couples therapist working on attachment
issues uh pull them out and then discuss
them with you so that's what we're going
to do today and
well actually before we get started for
the people that haven't heard you before
because the show's grown a lot since the
last time you were on briefly what's
your background
yeah so as a psychotherapist for years
marriage and family therapist and what I
found through my training and through
training other Healthcare professionals
was that attachment was the vehicle
underneath that was driving all of the
diagnoses that we saw in the book but
what they were teaching therapists was
that they only needed to treat the
diagnoses because nobody understands
attachment Theory it is terribly
misunderstood and it became my obsession
and my specialty so I've been training
and experiencing this and everything
working with people on this for 15 years
now through this process I retired my
license as a psychotherapist so that I
could coach internationally and help
people everywhere with attachment issues
and I am working hard to change this
game that says attachment is just
something women study when they want to
cry more and I'm teaching especially now
men that I have found in coaching men
through fixing their attachment in a way
that is practical and makes sense to
them so that you can overcome a lifetime
of dating problems insecurities fears
and everything else that comes with
broken attachment beautiful okay my
first favorite one that I picked up
recently most couples that therapy is
useless not because the therapy is wrong
but because most couples don't go to
therapy together until one of them is
absolutely not wanting to work on the
relationship anymore they're using
therapy as an excuse to air their
frustration one last time
so many times I've had couples come in
and that's exactly what it is is one is
all in for it and it's convinced I'm
going to fix their partner and tell them
that they've been right all along and
the other partner comes in dreading it
because their partner is the one who set
it up and they say what and what sort of
Buzz saw am I walking into and it is a
miserable experience for all three
people involved unless I can turn them
around and convince the other partner
that I'm there to help them in which
case the first partner can is convinced
that I have somehow pulled a Switcheroo
and they are now going to get betrayed
by their by their coach now who's
working with them it's an ugly process
it is really ugly the only time couples
therapy really works is when they are
coming in because they both want to make
it work but they don't have the skills
and they have no no idea what to do if
they both want to make it work it's an
amazing experience if one of them
doesn't want to work and doesn't have
the guts to say it it's a horrible
experience for both people why is it so
rare for couples to go to couples
therapy before the stage that one of
them is basically ready to call it quits
and needs uh an Arbiter between the two
of them because most people do not have
the skills they need to speak to their
partner proactively and productively
about the problems so they just pretend
there aren't problems or they throw
anger and excuses at each other over and
over and over again one will try the
other withdrawals then they've switched
and the other tries again and the other
one with drugs and they only vent to the
people around them they don't actually
go out and get proactive solutions from
the people around them and their family
systems are usually broken so they've
never seen a healthy relationship they
think this is as good as it gets they
only seek professional help when one of
them panics because the other one has
made a change and I will also say this
women change for relationships typically
men only will change for circumstances
which is reality women will usually be
done with a relationship a year or more
before they're actually ready to get
divorced men have no idea that this is
coming men get blindsided and they say
wait I'm finally willing to give it a
try let's try couples therapy and she's
been done for a year so this is a very
common problem right there do you think
that that explains part of the reason
and that most divorces are initiated by
women absolutely at one hundred percent
because most women have spent 5 10 20
years changing for the relationship
hoping that her husband will secretly
somehow change for the relationship too
men only change when they observe a
problem and then when they believe that
there is a solvable problem there that
they can actually work on it takes both
of those things for a man to actually
work on something most men will only
change enough to try to stop the
discomfort that they're experiencing and
try to go backward
um
yeah it's uh I have a number of friends
that have either been through couples
counseling or are going to couples
counseling at the moment and I would say
that the archetype is as you've
described that it really is
if this counseling was to make the
relationship better it is a severe
uphill battle which I imagine from a
therapist's perspective makes couples
counseling
um not exactly fun
so I went through school graduate
program six years for master's degree
and then additional three years of
apprenticeship of hard apprenticeship
under clinicians so it's nine-year
process to become a marriage and family
therapist at nine years of training of
them telling us you will want to you
will get burned out on this job couple's
therapy is hard couples don't actually
usually get better very few of them do
it's hard work and you have to
completely detach from their outcomes
because otherwise you will drive
yourself crazy watching One couple after
another tear themselves apart there's
nothing you can do to help them this is
the message they gave us and it was very
true you you come in you do the best
that you can and you guide them forward
and usually the biggest piece that I
would do is this is get them to a point
where they could say what got you
together in the first place where do you
have any commonalities and where is
there even a sliver of Hope that both of
you could work together on this if
there's even a tiny shred of hope we can
make this work I well really briefly one
time I had a couple come in to my
coaching practice they both had very
very bad attachment very bad attachment
neither one of them knew it one of them
was having an affair the other one
wanted the relationship to work the one
who was having an affair wasn't sure if
they wanted it to work or not I educated
them on attachment first session
educated fully on attachment second
session got them working on bonding
together and doing what couples are
supposed to do third session taught them
communication skills and conflict
resolution by the fourth session when
they walked in
both of them were happier in their
relationship than they had ever been
even as newlyweds even as whether we're
dating the person was cheating and said
absolutely not I'm going to do this
marriage it's amazing they had healed
their attachment together and they were
now growing closer to their friends and
their family at the same time it only
took three sessions of doing the Deep
work because both of them were committed
to it if a couple wants to make it work
even extreme circumstances can work but
you must both want to make it work
how does
a pair of people who have got ingrained
responses habituated thought patterns uh
um routines built into their
communication style the way they relate
to each other the way that they show up
to each other
how can it be the case that three
sessions is all that it takes to
deprogram something which at the very
least we're taught should take 66 days
to break and make a new habit that's
absolutely true it's absolutely true
it's curious because here's the piece is
so many people are living with a
decision they made when they were one
year old that said I am scared I am hurt
I am sad I feel vulnerable people will
abandon me or people will betray me
there is something wrong with me or with
other people and I am not ever going to
be able to be open again because I will
never be this hurt that scared this
vulnerable ever again for the rest of my
life they don't even remember this
decision but that foundational belief
has been set into their brain as an
absolute fact of the universe gravity
pulls things down water is wet and love
is impossible and I must live in fear
for the rest of my life to stay safe
that foundational belief once you hear
it and say well I have been believing
that but it's probably true and someone
comes in an attachment expert comes in
and says it is not true here's an
alternate model for living that is
possible I want you to think about it
over the next week and tell me if it's
ruining your life or if this is
something that we could fix and they'll
think about it and it ruins it for them
and then they start seeing the Matrix
and they say wow maybe there is two
different ways to live and maybe I've
been living the wrong way maybe I'm
willing to learn and then they learn it
once you've got it intellectually cool
once you experience it that's where it
begins to change because when you
experience the difference your brain
chemistry balances out right we've got I
deal with the five big brain chemicals
there's more than this but the five big
ones we work we look at phosphorus and
oxytocin Gaba gamma aminobioric acid and
serotonin those four are absolutely
crucial to get through your good
relationships if you don't have good
relationships you've got a dopamine
button that you can punch like a monkey
this is where people have porn addiction
and all kinds of addictions and phone
addictions and gambling addictions it's
because their brain chemistry is off
from their wounded relationships that
they've never been fulfilled it is like
a duck that is terrified of water so it
lives its whole life on land it's like a
duck who will never fly because it's
terrified of the sky as well it's a duck
who is continuously walking because it
thinks water or flying is going to kill
it that's what these people are like as
they experience even a little bit the
overwhelming brain chemistry that floods
through them from good relationships is
like a duck who finally learns to swim
or finally flies and says this is not
just not scary it is exhilarating it's
everything I was built for your brain is
built for these things and the addiction
to the good takes over and it heals you
much more rapidly than most people are
expecting it is not about habits it is
about cultivating the right experiences
so that your brain takes over for you
the public school system treats boys
like defective girls then raises girls
to act more like boys check the cdc's
medication rates for ADHD in boys and
antidepressants in girls what's going on
there
the American school system is designed
to churn people out into factory
settings or turn people out into a
prison setting or a corporate setting in
a cubicle and it is not designed for
young boys who are not designed for
corporations are not designed for
cubicles prisons and and factories it is
simply not going to work that way so it
punishes people who stick out and it
medicates them down we have the medical
system here in America the medical model
of mental health I work with the
response model if something is off the
person's not responding right or the
situation is not right there's something
happening where we need to change their
response not medicate them into Oblivion
because there's something wrong with
their brain boys are not defective girls
boys are boys and we need to create a
system for them
why the female set point why presume
that boys should act like defective
girls
it's the same reason that overseas when
American companies ship their jobs
overseas they usually pull in female
workers into their sweatshops because
they are quiet they are more compliant
they just sit there they do what they're
told and they will do the tiny tasks
over and over and over and then go home
without complaining they are most
unlikely to complain or cause a fuss
they will simply do what they're told
that is why that's the model that we
want here in America for boys so you've
got higher agreeableness a little bit
higher on average conscientiousness I
mean you know you'd look at the rates in
schools at the moment and girls are out
achieving boys when the Title IX and
some adjustments have been made the way
that the education system works and I
think it is plain that the current
version of schooling that you have
is more suited to a female nature or you
could in Reverse say that female nature
is more suited to the current iteration
of of schooling there is a conspiracy
out there that says that school has been
purposefully sort of um reprogrammed to
um make it more difficult for boys I
would be much more tempted to presume
that it's just a easier it's not a
coordinated effort to keep boys down by
the school system it's simply the way to
have the most peaceful sort of classroom
and each individual teacher is
optimizing for the most peaceful
classroom which is the one where
students aren't doing things with their
hands where they're not running around
outside where there's easily structured
timetables homework as opposed to exams
all of these sorts of things they are
they are done out of convenience not out
of malign coordination
absolutely yeah it's there's there's
enough idiocy in the world without
bringing malice into it
it's okay to be sad that doesn't mean
you're depressed it's okay to be worried
that doesn't mean you're anxious it's
okay to experience trauma that doesn't
mean you have PTSD not everything is a
diagnosable issue
so many people hide behind a diagnosis
and say I never have to get better this
is one of the biggest things with
attachment issues too people take an
attachment Styles quiz and say oh I'm
anxious attachment I will be that for
the rest of my life absolutely not that
is the medical system that says you have
a disease we must treat you for the rest
of your life you will go through 10
years of therapy and take five
medications as I was working as a
psychologist as a psychotherapist I did
in-home treatment for people and some of
my clients were on 27 different
medications at the same time and I would
ask them what they were for and they
would not know and at least 12 to 15 of
those medications would be psychological
medications some of them were four or
five different antidepressants and then
three or different anxiety medications
and then some for panic disorder and
then some for who knows they just kept
throwing them in they had no idea that's
the American system right now and if you
have a diagnosis
it's not the end of your life and not
everything is a diagnosis a diagnosis
should just say here's where you're
starting where are you going to go
there's something very reassuring in a
way I think about pathologizing your
emotions about giving them a label it's
not that the world is unfair that life
is difficult that sometimes bad things
happen people pass away you become
destitute or broke or or ill or sick or
your family members die it's not that
it's that you have X or Y or Zed it is a
forcing function a convenient way to
reduce down the complexity of the world
and I see it in myself I see it in my
friends I see it in the people that talk
about this sort of stuff online
it is a very seductive solution to try
and have a label that you can place
behind something it's not that your
sleep pattern is very bad because of
your poor habits around eating late at
night which causes your digestive system
to cause you to not eat well and you're
drinking too much water and now you've
got uh like shy bladder syndrome or
you've got a like a a bladder problem
that means you've got to go to the
bathroom or whatever it is which is
causing your sleep to be bad which means
that Downstream from that your anxiety
is higher the next day it's I'm anxious
I've got I've got anxiety I've got an
anxiety problem and um yeah reducing
down the complexity of the world into a
pathology ADHD we saw it before it's
like oh yeah giving that diagnosis the
number of ADHD diagnoses has gone up was
it like 10 times 50 times or something
that's overwhelming the amount in
America they say one in seven little
boys in America is now medicated for
ADHD I mean that's those are all brutal
medications do you know how many boys
I've talked to and grown men who are in
their 20s that say I've been medicated
for ADHD since I was four years old I've
been on I've been on stimulants since I
was four years old because my preschool
teacher diagnosed me with ADHD and told
them my parents they would kick me out
of school if I didn't get on meds a lot
guys have never lived their real life
what how would you describe I don't know
whether you've ever been on ADHD
medication but from what you know about
the experience of it what can you tell
me about
what life would be like before and after
for a young boy or girl and then also
moving up into adulthood
most of what I encounter is people whose
brain is so fried from years and years
and years of being doped up and
zombified and then still being screamed
at any time they twitch wrong they move
wrong they act wrong they don't do
something right it's you have ADHD
that's your ADHD get under control I
don't want to tolerate you you have this
problem people who have ADHD sometimes
it's not ADHD sometimes it's an
attachment issue other times people have
ADHD have attachment issues from being
yelled at for having actual ADHD it's
amazing how those two go hand in hand
and those medications zombify you and
then you've been on them for 20 years
and you've never experienced what it's
like not to be run down and also not to
be yelled at for having a diagnosis it's
it's not just even the meds it's the
whole experience of being told there is
something wrong with you and you will
never function right
what was that psychological experiment
where they
took children who had minor stutters and
emphasized the stutter yeah so they
encouraged one group and said hey
encourage them and the stutter got
better the other one they stressed them
out to the Max and it made it so bad
some of them couldn't even talk it was
100 if you encourage the heel ADHD by
the way some people call it type e
personality entrepreneur some people who
thrive in entrepreneurial settings have
very ADHD style brains and behaviors and
they can do amazing when you get them in
the right areas boys with with diagnosed
at least with ADH do do amazingly well
in non-traditional schools when you get
them in there their achievement goes
through the roof but that's not what
we're doing we're not focusing on that
because we have a one-size-fits-all
education model not everybody's got
access to a Waldorf School or some sort
of outdoorsy type thing which means that
if you are a child or a young boy or
perhaps a girl who has ADHD you are a
square peg being shoved into an
incredibly round hole and there are very
few Alternatives I think is it Elon Musk
who dropped out of Stamford after his
first seminar I think he I think he
lasted less than half a term or
something and you know you're looking at
a guy whatever you think of his
philosophy and his politics and his
businesses who is very capable at doing
a lot of diverse things that screams
just like uh weaponized commercialized
ADHD to me it is it is weaponized ADHD
is right and that's why he can achieve
the way he does most likely when you
harness it right it's an incredible
power when you live in a society where
everything is one size fits all then you
are a giant living in a City for very
short people and nothing is going to fit
right you're going to bang your head
everywhere you go let's also remember
that saying you know having an ADHD
problem every pathology that you want to
talk about is a spectrum you know even
the most focused person in the world is
the first percentile on the spectrum of
ADHD there's no point at which you hit a
marker and it's like oh at this point
you're ADHD even you could say this
about obesity right when you name
somebody as being obese it's actually a
kind of arbitrary line that's like okay
above BMI of this particular thing and
BMI is just this decision tool that
you've decided to use but we're talking
about Spectrum here and ADHD is a
function of a bunch of other uh like
phenomena and manifestations the way
that people behave and show up in the
world the same thing would be true for
anxiety for depression for whatever it
might be and
pathologizing it as well using it as a
label using it as an identifier is like
okay up to a point at what point do you
say that you're that you are ADHD or
that you're just somebody that happens
to have a more wandering imagination and
really how useful is it to be able to
get yourself to that set I mean Robert
Plowman what is he the third most cited
psychologist of the uh 20th century the
pre-eminent behavioral uh geneticist in
in the world
um he said that all of these diagnoses
as far as he can see are basically
pointless because everything's just a
spectrum so it makes it easy when you
want to diagnose somebody when you want
to come up with a solution but
it's not tremendously useful at them
understanding themselves because
everybody is on this spectrum everybody
has different bits of all of these
thrown in when I was at graduate school
one thing they told us was when do you
undiagnose someone and everyone in the
room looked around and said what do you
mean everyone when they get a diagnosis
they just have it and they said no you
undiagnosed them when in the book it
says when you can function well in your
relationships and you can function well
in school or work those are the two
requirements you must have functional
impairment from the issue if you can get
a person to where they are fully
functional they are no longer impaired
they no longer fit the diagnosis you
remove the diagnosis at that point and
say you no longer have this diagnosis
the problem is we have removed that
entire part from the book in our heads
and no one undiagnoses anymore and
diagnosis is now a permanent thing for
the rest of your life that is not even
built into the book that is built into
our culture so you just spend your time
accumulating and never riding yourself
of different pathologies how funny okay
next one there's two together that I
really enjoyed here most men avoid
therapy because most therapy approaches
are not designed to help the male brain
deal with pain or find solutions that
makes men believe therapy is worthless
and Men skip things that feel worthless
also male depression is usually based on
feeling helpless powerless and unable to
affect one's life or environment therapy
models focus on helping men feel heard
and loved instead of restoring their
sense of personal power men need
Solutions not just feelings absolutely
and we are churning out here in the
United States an overwhelming number of
therapists who do not have the skills
that they need or the experience that
they need to provide lasting solutions
that will undiagnose you in the long
term there are not it's not that every
therapist is bad I was a therapist for
years there's many of my colleagues who
are wonderful however the system we are
doing here in America is to desperately
churn out as many Health Care Providers
as we can because we do not have enough
of them and to focus their training in
specifically on the diagnostic and
statistics manual so that you can treat
issues and then you're going to be
coupled in with all kinds of medication
and problems are not unfixable because
you're just medicating and triaging so
much of mental health in America is
based on the medical model and endless
triage endless triage management symptom
management that's all it is for the rest
of their life and when you get a man
into that system men would rather kill
themselves than sit there and say I am
disabled I must have a medical help a
medical assistance for the rest of my
life and all I can do is sit here and
talk about my feelings endlessly for the
next 10 years while paying ten thousand
dollars for the privilege that is not
what men are looking for men are looking
for Solutions and they're looking for
guidance in how to apply those Solutions
when you give them those things men will
do just about anything for you why is a
problem why is it a problem for therapy
models to focus on helping men feel
heard and loved instead of restoring
their sense of personal power why is
that something which is uniquely male
and why is that the approach that
therapy models have when trying to fix
men the brain scans show us that the
male brain goes backwards to observe and
then forwards to act upon it it mostly
goes like this back observe forward act
when we see a problem we act upon that
problem that's how the male brain tends
to work the female brain tends to
observe in the back and they go back and
forth across the hemispheres and make a
bunch of connections and process it and
then think about it and and pull pieces
out and make deeper connections that
that is often why women communicate to
process with each other to share with
each other and they need to feel heard
they are also fairly risk averse
typically so a woman doesn't typically
want to be the one who makes the final
decision but they value being heard so
they can have input on a group decision
that all of them their brains go back
and forth and back and forth and make a
decision together so that there is
shared reliability and shared
responsibility among the group men want
to observe and act upon it and solve the
problem when you have a therapy model
that just makes men feel heard and loved
okay they kind of feel heard I feel
heard and they kind of feel loved well I
kind of feel loved now I I feel like a
useless piece of helpless garbage that
other people are sitting here loving
that means they just pity me and I am
just an endless creature of pity who
will never solve any problems it almost
makes them worse is there a point where
it helps men to feel hurt and loved
absolutely do men not need to feel heard
loved no they do but it just makes them
feel like they are being pitied and that
is something men would rather die than
experience for the most part you said as
well uh most therapy approaches are not
designed to help the male brain deal
with pain or find Solutions what's the
deal with painoma I can see the fine
Solutions that's the back and forth
that's the I have the information it's
time for me to enact something what
about the the deal with pain thing most
women when they experience pain what
they will typically do is look for
comfort with other people look to share
that and be nurtured as they experience
the pain women are very adaptable they
are wonderfully adaptable so they endure
through the pain by building connections
and relying on those connections men
hate that when men experience pain if
they then have to go and just be a
burden to someone else they feel
worthless they would rather March off
into the Wilderness and die most
typically men need to deal with pain by
finding a way through it and finding a
purpose through it so that they can push
through that pain push through the pain
receptors push through that and follow
that mission if you do that men can go
through the pain and put it in its place
because they no longer feel helpless
against the pain there is a reason for
enduring the pain that's what men need
can you tell that story about The Blitz
in World War II again
yeah so there's research that shows
through the Blitz in World War II
psychiatric men psychiatric hospitalized
men who were comatose they would sit
there they were just miserable
wretchedly miserable but when things
started happening around them and
Society needed them when the bombs start
going off when everything happened they
were needed all of a sudden they had a
reason to get up and go do something and
that impelled them to pull out of their
pain out of their struggle out of
everything and go do what they were
supposed to do it is the same thing as a
depressed man who is finally called up
to do something and goes and does it in
his family in his life men who were who
are low and low and low and then they
find out that the woman in their life is
carrying their child and all of a sudden
it Sparks a difference in him right he
stops drinking he gets he cleans himself
up same experience I will endure the
pain for the sake of my family my
country my people my whatever it may be
here is my chance to rise up and make
this change that is what men are built
for
does the fact that a man with a strong
enough y can bear anyhow
which is a nice synopsis I guess of what
you're sort of touching on there
does this explain why Modern Men are so
insecure
that there is a massive lack of purpose
relationships around them we have more
childless men than ever we have no
intergenerational pan generational
homesteads anymore there is a lack at
least in the west of patriotism of
nationalism
um
what first off why are modern men so
insecure and then secondly how does what
we've just spoken about play into that
so many of the men who come into my
coaching program are lacking what I call
human impact they have no ability to
create human impact in their life that's
what a legacy is is the lasting human
impact that endures after your death it
does not have to be biological children
although that's one of the easiest ones
to point out and create it can be
adopted children it can be mentored
people that you help it can be people
you rescue it can be an organization
that you build a human impact is the
purpose of a man's life because someday
you will die you will be dust your money
will be fritted away and taken through
taxes and all kinds of things your
property will be divvied up yours you're
everything you've cared for in your life
will be taken away the only thing that
endures is the future Generations who
are fundamentally altered because of
your existence on this planet that is
the purpose of a man's life that is why
so many men want to kill themselves now
is because they find no purpose and no
ability to create human impact
why
would it be adaptive for a man to have
that or how do women and their life
goals and purpose differ from that
it's funny because many women and I've
worked with tons of these women they
have much the same purpose women are
much more adaptable but they want to be
useful to the people in their life and
help enhance those people's lives so
they can go out and live and Thrive
women are about helping other people
thrive men are about changing the course
of other people's life if you want to
look at it that way women can find that
purpose just about anywhere helping just
about anybody as long as they have
usefulness women can be very happy if
they are loved and feel useful to the
people that they love that's when most
women are okay and they can endure they
can crawl over broken glass but they
aren't looking for the overall
life-changing creation that men are
looking for they're looking for enduring
and helping people endure and nurture
them as they go whereas men are capable
Mission powerful
absolutely that's what men are looking
for interesting you've been helping some
of your clients to detox from Red Pill
fears what's happening absolutely
um
so many men who grow up either insecure
with insecure attachment they say
something's wrong with me I don't know
what women want from me I'm scared of
women you know I'll try to please them
like I please my mom and then they're
not happy about that and then what am I
supposed to do how do I ask for sex how
do I communicate my needs what do I do
like we're in a weird Society women are
kind of confusing dating was really hard
it seems like women are really picky
what do I do then they encounter a woman
who hurts their feelings usually a woman
who's very chaotic may have a
personality disorder borderline
personality disorder stands out pretty
hard among the women who really
devastate these men and they have such a
horrible breakup experience that they're
agonized and then they find online
somebody who's willing to say look women
really are horrible red pill culture
teaches women have borderline
personality disorder all of them it's
normal for women to feel that way they
don't even feel anything like humans do
they don't feel like men do they are
incapable of loving you the way you want
to be loved there's a book I believe
that I'm pulling that quote from which
is a big red pill Bible that they use uh
women are not capable of the depth of
loyalty and love that you are you have
every reason to feel scared of women and
you need to control them and that is
just all it does is switch men from
anxious attachment style where I think I
am the problem to avoid attachment style
everyone else is the problem and I must
manage them like livestock while getting
sex from them and then dump them the
moment they try to build any kind of
intimacy or connection with me and make
them live in fear all the time and
that's what red pill does is swap from
one horrible life system to a different
life system that's just as horrible if
not worse guys come into my coaching
practice and say Adam I hate how I have
hurt women for the last five years I am
lonely I am miserable and I'm realizing
this sucks what is the alternative is
there even an alternative it seems like
everyone it seems like red pill is right
but I'm just as miserable as I was
before what do I do and I pull them in
and I guide them through what other they
have slept with 300 women or have never
slept with a woman before because red
pill has made them so petrified of women
that they are terrified they're going to
be eaten alive I guide them through that
because there is a third option which is
to actually be a human being who
connects to other human beings with
trust with honesty and understanding
what red and green flags to look for in
relationships and how to communicate
with women as if they are human beings
too and that's the magic
what
if you could go in and Tinker with the
current world of men's dating advice red
pill Manos very stuff what would be the
main lessons that you would try to
dispense with
talk about commitment more
and be very clear about what you want
every woman who comes into my dating
practice is scared to death to say I
just want to find one man to marry and
have children with and be with for the
rest of my life but if I mention that to
any man before a year three he is going
to get up and run screaming from me and
the men who come into my coaching
practice say I just want one woman to be
with for the rest of my life and have
children but if I mention that before
year three she will think I'm a psycho
who's trying to control her men it makes
you so attractive when you are very
clear what you want but you must
understand that you also have to pass
tests that prove that that is actually
what you want you don't have to pass
tests proving that you are an eight foot
tall millionaire who sweats diamonds and
drives Lamborghinis you must prove that
you are a man of substance who is out
there to make change in the world any
kind of change and who is reliable and
consistent so that you could be
dependent upon in a family situation
that is really all it takes and most men
cannot pass that test if you can learn a
past that test
women will very much desire you for a
lifelong relationship how do women enact
that test
women enact that test typically because
they believe your words up front but
over time they begin testing you they
begin challenging you when you do
something that is completely against
what you have claimed you want in life
when you say yeah I want a committed
loving relationship and then you're
secretly scrolling through porn when you
say yeah I want to get married but maybe
in like eight years when you say I'd
love to have kids and you have never
interacted with a child in your life and
you have zero interest in children and
keep pushing them away from you when
they try to talk to you when you are
just smoking pot in your underwear
playing Xbox instead of building a
business a side business or advancing in
a career or doing anything they look at
that and say where are you at like
you're not actually doing anything what
are you doing be the man she would want
to be married to instead of promising
her that you are going to change into
the man she wants to be married to do
that on the way to building your good
life you will find a woman who wants the
kind of man you're becoming
do you not think that current men's
advice
touches on that topic
current men's advice says either
completely disregard women as you build
your Empire
or be so fearful of women that you end
up manipulating them and playing games
with them because that's all that
they're capable of doing with you and
you must keep them at arm's length to
keep yourself safe that is by large the
majority of men's advice that's out
there on the internet right there and
it's terrible well I'm looking at this
very deeply at the moment and one of the
trends that I would love to try and tune
down is this adversarial relationship
between men and women and I understand I
think that you know there's a little bit
of credence to say that
men's and women's dating strategies
mating strategies in some regard can be
a little bit adversarial
we are evolutionarily programmed for
them to not always align perfectly but
on average they have to align at least
some of the time or else there wouldn't
be a [__] civilization so that and
it's not really so much about the
adversarial nature because let's you
know even if you're the biggest Dan
Bilzerian Chad in the world you're only
talking about you and like 10 Birds
right it's only you and 10 girls that
you can have let's say that it is
exclusively uh
refined and constrained within dating
and mating that's your adversarial
relationship okay that means that
there's
3.5 billion minus 10 women on the planet
with whom you should be able to have a
non-adversarial relationship and yeah
and this isn't just coming from the
men's side this is absolutely r slash
the pink pill R female dating strategy
you know all of that stuff that's just
as toxic that comes from the women's
side
um all of that stuff says the other sex
is the enemy they are someone that you
should fundamentally mistrust
fundamentally any gain that they have is
your loss and any gain that you have is
their loss the goal is to walk away from
the table with as many points on your
side as possible and as few points on
their side as possible or just discount
what what the situation is left with
it's so scarcity mindseted it's so
negative some not even like neutral some
it's straight up negative some scenario
and that adversarial relationship
between
both mating and non-mating men with
women blows my mind let me tell you
exactly where that comes from it comes
from something called avoidant
attachment style avoiding attachment
styles of belief from childhood that
there's something fundamentally wrong
with other people that they are
incapable of acting morally just or with
any kind of faithfulness towards you
when the stress is on that they will
always default to selfishness so you
must endlessly pump up their positive
feelings to then get them to do what you
want them to do in return but you must
also keep them at arm's length so they
can never get in deep enough to see your
human weaknesses betray you turn on you
rip you apart that is avoiding
attachment style it comes in two
different flavors there's the nervous
type where they just try to keep safe
from other people and then there's the
manipulative type of coercing
controlling other human beings these two
can lead into things like anti-social
personality disorder narcissistic
personality disorder that's the extremes
what you're dealing with on both sides
is avoidant men and avoidant women who
want all of this they want the pleasure
without any real responsibility in the
relationship because they are fearful
and it's not just the other side that
they are fearful of they are equally as
fearful of their own side it's just that
they're trying to sleep with the other
side so it makes them more vulnerable to
the other side than to their own side
that is what is happening there it's
avoid an attachment style setting the
definition for dating throughout the
entire world because then they go out
and the secure people and the insecure
anxious people try to earn their
approval and live with them and connect
with them they set the tone for the
entire dating pool for them for the
whole world that way
how effective have you been at
deprogramming red pill ideology from Men
Who maybe don't have a lot of real world
experience I have men come in who are so
deeply terrified of women that it is
like working with the worst trauma cases
that I worked with back in the day and
in a low-income high-risk Clinic it is
like the ER of trauma experience men
come in so overwhelmingly petrified they
can't even imagine opening up to a woman
what I teach them is exactly how to do
that in a few sessions and when they
experience it it feels so good that they
are a duck learning to swim in water for
the first time and then they realize how
good it actually feels and the
experience they have scares the crap out
of them so they leap backwards and then
pull back but then they ease back into
it again as she reassures him as she
doesn't pull out a knife and stab him in
the heart like red pill has proven that
like it will happen no she actually
Embraces it and enjoys the intimacy with
him and he enjoys it too it is just a
matter of can he believe it or not is he
willing to give it a shot if he's
willing to give it a shot we can get him
there through experience what would you
say to the guys that follow the red pill
ideology I would say that's blue pill
white night thinking you don't
understand how women actually work this
is you don't you don't understand the
Dynamics between the Sexes if you open
up to a woman like that she's not going
to accept you you're going to end up
being hurt and she's going to sleep with
the six foot four Lumberjack that lives
next door yeah I would say that if she
has severe personality disorders maybe
she would the number of women who have
severe personality disorders is
excessively low if you look at the
actual number of women who have
overwhelming numbers of Partners and
just leap but you'll find that it's it's
brutally low it's a tiny sliver of the
female population that do that and is
down to very much personality disorders
or extreme avoidant attachment style
most women are just looking for a loving
relationship to be with you and feel
safe with you and build a family with
you and be the wind at your back as you
achieve your goals through the rest of
your life that is what the vast majority
of women actually want and I say that as
a man who's built my own business who
has four children of the woman I've been
married with for 14 years now marriage
and family therapist for years now a
dating expert and dating coach I have
seen this through thousands and
thousands and thousands of relationships
women just want that love with you it is
nothing like what you have heard but
yes there are women out there who can't
hurt you and you've probably been hurt
and your experience right now is one of
one or three of three because you
attract those women because your own
problems attract those women because you
by your nature reject the good women
learn how to not reject the good women
learn how to be a good man yourself in
Romance and in love and you will find
the right woman and if you can't I will
show you how to do that one of the
interesting things that I've realized
when uh doing a little bit more research
about the current trend of dating and
understanding what's going on and
specifically the men's online space is
that as both men and women have become
increasingly anti-social because they
have better things to do with their time
whether that's spending time in the
internet or just generally being
distracted by porn video games or
whatever else
your real world experiences with the
opposite sex diminish you have fewer and
fewer of those experiences to disprove
stories that you hear on the internet
and by Design the stories that catch the
most attention on the internet are the
most egregious transgressions of
whatever sacred cow or Norm it is that
you think should be accepted if some
woman
while her husband goes out to get the
milk [__] the mailman and and and and
his dog and he comes back to find that
all three of them in bed together you go
well yeah obviously that's going to get
a hundred thousand upvotes on Reddit
because it's [__] insane and you
that's not me saying that this sort of
stuff doesn't happen the dog thing maybe
not but the the point being that there
are vicious both men and women out there
who are very malign and have and have a
ton of malice in them and you know
massive red flags
but because a lot of the world has no
ulterior Real World experience to
disprove this you end up with that model
being used as oh well this is what all
women are like
um and I had a I posted an episode a
couple of days ago and I had a very very
interesting uh comment I'm gonna read
out here
the problem for many of us is this
anyone dysfunctional enough to put up
with us is going to be too dysfunctional
or untrustable for us to handle in
return
and there was a reply to that that said
I actually had a rule like this while I
was in university informed by the
disaster that was my first uni
relationship if she approaches me she's
interested in someone much better than
me and she that she invented wearing my
skin I'm not going to be able to compete
with that guy how would you I'm aware
you don't know much about these two
commenters but how would you analyze the
two people that I've just mentioned that
sounds like like learned helplessness
learned helplessness is this belief that
you can never get better so where you're
at is all you will ever be so you are a
piece of steaming garbage then people
are attracted to steaming garbage no fix
yourself if you say I'm attracting
disasters then stop being a disaster and
stop attracting disasters people you can
change please take the time to learn the
skills to change please take the time to
learn the mindsets of changing you are
not a static creature you are Dynamic
creature you can and should be changing
husbands who complain about having zero
sex have no idea how the female sex
drive actually works and the complaining
makes it much worse
my favorite thing is when couples come
in and they haven't had sex in a year
and I ask why and she looks at him and
says because he hasn't asked and he says
well I kind of hinted and you just never
seemed interested and she says well when
was the last time you spent time with me
well why would I spend time with you if
you're not having sex with me and that
right there is exactly the spiral women
after one year their sex drive switches
from bonding with you mode to long-term
stability and mate retention if you have
given her the adequate emotional bonding
and if she has decent enough secure
enough attachment to receive that
bonding her sex drive will go way up
because her brain says keep this man
around and have as many of his babies as
I can we must have 15 babies in the next
week that's what her brain will say and
I've seen couples I've worked with
couples in their 60s who come in and
sorry for this mental image but they
come in having very little sex and they
leave after a few sessions having sex
three or four or five times a week in
their 60s because they improve their
actual emotional intimacy which leads to
better non-sexual physical intimacy
which then leads overwhelmingly to
sexual physical intimacy it should begin
in your emotional bonding and connection
it will drive her sex drive through the
roof and she will not only be receptive
to you she will be chasing you through
the house
yeah you had another tweet that said at
about 6-12 months into a relationship
the female sex drive switches from
attraction and bonding to long-term
stability that means emotional intimacy
trust and predictability many couples
lack these three things so her sex drive
tanks neither person fully gets why
so many women that I work with do not
understand how their own sex drive works
I I have clients who come in and they
say Adam I don't know why I don't have a
high sex drive I just feel like my
husband is mad at me for not having sex
with her but I just kind of don't want
to what's the problem and I say well you
don't want to because he's not doing
what he's supposed to be doing as your
husband they say oh thank you for saying
that I say okay well what would it take
well I don't know just like maybe more
time together and so we run through a
list of exactly like 12 to 15 things of
what spending time together should look
like and then we give him a measurable
list of do this do this do this do this
often this amount of time this level do
this and they do it for a week or two
and all of a sudden her sex drive goes
through the roof and they're very happy
um so
I remember reading in Jonathan Heights
the happiness hypothesis about the
passionate and companionate uh two
styles of of it's not quite attachment I
think it's attraction perhaps
is there an equivalent for men
for these emotional intimate bonding
like this yeah so you've said that with
women around about six to 12 months the
the arousal response occurs due to
different stimulus stimuli is there an
equipment for men
there is
um
yes okay here's what it mostly is I'm
trying to frame it people don't usually
ask that so let's talk about this the
male sex drive typically works if we
have resources then we want to go
reproduce because we have enough
resources to protect whatever would
happen if we reproduced that's a cheap
way of saying it but the male brain has
to say look if I'm going to throw
endless resources at something I need to
make sure it's actually going to be
sustainable and that everything is going
to continue the way it needs to so if a
woman is betraying him if a woman is
completely
anti-maternal usually if a woman is
actively hurting him and attacking him
or if his stress level is overwhelmingly
high from his environment that's where
the man's sex drive typically goes down
it takes pretty significant factors of
this is not sustainable for a man's sex
drive to tank that hard it's it's tough
not impossible but tough I do know that
bonding through oxytocin actually and
she helps men achieve faster erection
and more lasting erections so oxytocin
is very important for men it's the
bonding hormone you get through motion
intimacy but it is very important but
men can still endure without it it takes
a lot to turn off the male sex drive
we're a little bit more simple creatures
I think we are comes to that what was
what was it that you taught me about the
role of vasopressin for men during sex
so the research shows that when men have
orgasms it works a little bit different
than how women have orgasms women will
have orgasms and they their orgasm
happens largely due to an overwhelming
supply of oxytocin that causes massive
constrictions through the uterus and
same same hormone that causes
um labor and birth we have a synthetic
version that we use called pitocin that
actually induces labor it's synthetic
oxytocin and women flood with that
during sex and that's what leads to one
orgasm which then leads to another and
then leads to ten and then leads to her
having a toe tag because she's died but
that's what it's supposed to be men have
one orgasm if they get any and oxytocin
may or may not affect the male brain as
much as it does the female brain it
seems to more be there to move the semen
along and he may Bond a bit with you
through oxytocin but men have far more
receptors for vasopressin vasopressin is
the hormone responsible for bonding when
you achieve a mission together you solve
a problem together you accomplish a goal
together you know men are goal oriented
who could have predicted that if he
accomplishes in sex with you and says
we're going to give you 10 orgasms most
women respond by saying no let's not do
that or why the arbitrary number he is
actually setting a goal with you wants
to achieve it and wants to high-five
with you and that is actually going to
bond him to you more than his own orgasm
is going to bond him to you if you go
with him and accomplish a mission
together
that's going to be what does it so a
failure of cross-sex mind reading in
that women wouldn't understand why they
would create some arbitrary number of
this is how many pumps you're going to
give me before we finish or this is how
long it's going to last for this is how
whatever else it is
saying that to a woman is unlikely to
cause her to have
any additional bonding with you but to a
man placing some sort of challenge in
front of him that he can get to achieve
whilst also having sex sex being good
but achieving this okay so this together
as a team together as a team you achieve
that by the way that's the vasopressin
piece you your brain says we did this as
a team what else can we do as a team too
and it makes his brain say I want to
work with you to solve other problems as
well because now I have proven that you
are a good trustworthy Ally in my life
that's the key right there what is the
takeaway lesson for women in the bedroom
with regards to vasopressin and
maximizing that for men stop not asking
for orgasms stop just letting it not
happen stop just laying there and
closing your eyes and thinking of
England actually engage in it that's
right I'm okay I'm okay ladies that are
listening if you want to close your eyes
and think of England that's actually
certified by me as something that's
totally okay if she can say hey look
this is what does it for me help me
achieve this and I will be your best
friend uh and they do it and then tell
him that that was amazing and how great
it was and do it but mean it don't fake
it don't be don't be pretend do it and
accomplish it together and then
celebrate the win together that's the
other thing is most women are so
embarrassed when they have an orgasm do
it embrace it and celebrate the win
together as a team and man you guys are
both have a much better time I'll just
tell you that what
in your time
looking at the sex slides of men and
women were the most common reasons for
women struggling to achieve orgasm
usually because they have their own
attachment issues so they're either
avoidant where they fear oxytocin so
you'll see them pull away during
physical intimacy they will prefer to be
facing away from you during sex so that
there's not physical emotional intimacy
they will pull away after sex get their
clothes on really fast and try to pull
away and they're not comfortable with
that closeness that's one big one that I
work on as oxytocin aversion usually
through avoidant attachment the other is
anxious attachments so they're massively
insecure they are doing the sexual act
to try to please their partner it's not
like they're a prostitute they're trying
to make their partner feel good and feel
joyous and loving so their partner won't
abandon them they are trying to be
useful to their partner sex then is a
performance it's an act to make their
partner feel good they are absolutely
not focused on their own sex drive at
all
working as a couple's therapists for
years I didn't see even one divorce case
where at least one of the spouses didn't
have attachment issues every time but
most couples therapists aren't trained
in attachment and don't know to check
for that
attachment is what makes you connect to
another person so that you can say look
I'm gonna tell you the truth let's deal
with the truth we will get through it
together and we'll solve this problem if
you don't have secure attachment it is
very hard to cooperate to solve problems
then you get people who are just
defensive running away trying to escape
managing their partner pushing buttons
for years and years and years until they
reach a point where they have pushed too
hard and is now broken
I've seen especially since our first
conversation a massive proliferation of
discussions around attachment on the
internet I've had researchers like
Jessica bomb on the show she was
fantastic but I do sometimes worry about
people who talk about attachment getting
out over their skis a little and
um not only using it for situations
where it maybe doesn't apply but also
using it erroneously similar to how you
tried to
um sanitize some of the men's advice
earlier on what what are the what are
the things that attachment doesn't
explain doesn't do what would you tell
the world about attachment that it isn't
and that people need to dispel in terms
of attachments I get this all the time
people especially political Persuasions
start asking me hey is the other side
doing X because of attachment is it all
just down to attachment and what I tell
them is this attachment forms the
foundation of your life and it can
definitely color some choices but we
will not know some of the intricacies
until we fix attachment and then we need
to look at what remains and then we'll
be able to solve those problems together
as actual human beings working together
with respect for a human the human
dignity instead of screaming at each
other assuming everyone is our enemy
attachment doesn't touch everything it
touches a lot of things things but we
won't know what it doesn't touch until
we have fixed the massive epidemic in
our society that by the way is
increasing the research that I've seen
lately says up to 65 percent of people
now might likely have an attachment
issue and don't know it so the research
is is definitely proving it's going in
the wrong direction we need to turn that
around so that we can figure out what is
and is an attachment I also heard that
theories around attachment being
exclusively or even majorly contributed
to by childhood rearing are
coming under more and more scrutiny now
you know 50 of everything that you are
psychologically is heritable on average
so presumably there's a huge
heritability component here
um
are there any
elements of discussing attachment with
regards to Childhood rearing what what's
missed there do people get out over
their skis too much with regards to that
as well and and how else is attachment
contributed to
the biggest piece that I see is I have
people come to me and say Adam I think I
have attachment issues and I don't know
why my parents were actually pretty cool
they were actually pretty loving I don't
know what's wrong with me what I see is
people whose brains learned through
experience something called an
attachment wound through some sort of
painful experience your brain learned
that it is not safe and it will do
anything to avoid that it's like it's
like experiencing a trauma so being in
the NICU we call the NICU and the baby
comes out and they get put in there too
early they get put into an enclosed
chamber and they're trying to keep warm
but they don't get physical contact the
brain separates out and doesn't get what
it needs for those first few months a
child who's hurt a child who's abandoned
a child who's traumatized from birth up
until about age 12 your brain is trying
to learn through experience with your
peers with your parents with with people
in the world what is going to happen
your brain continues to learn beyond
that I much very much a follower of Carl
Jung who said that your brain is growing
throughout the course of your life you
can change I have people come in the
oldest client I I ever had was 79 years
old who came in and said I'd like to fix
my attachment okay let's fix the
attachment and we did that you can still
continue to change it is challenging
those beliefs yes they do come from
childhood no they are not set in stone
they continue to grow over time we are
not just creatures we are cognitive
beings and we have to embrace both sides
and we have to educate both sides if
that makes sense there was a really good
article from Vox that came out recently
about attachment what it explains and
what it doesn't and there was a section
in it that I put on my story today that
said knowing how you relate to romantic
Partners can be both helpful and a
hindrance focusing on attachment style
as an immovable obstacle can lead to a
loop of repeated mistakes instead a more
nuanced approach could offer insight
into your trigger points and how to move
Beyond them this is a quote I think it
has a beautiful capacity for growing
self-understanding and self-empathy
Karen says at the same time we've got to
make sure that we check ourselves enough
to go I'm not going to use cell both
knowing as self-justification to not
grow and to not change that is a really
really good I love that yep I love that
doesn't that go right back to the
discussion we had about getting
diagnosis and saying I have this for the
rest of my life that is the worst
mistake people make when they say Adam I
took an attachment Styles quiz and I am
simply anxious avoidance so I will just
be that and I say no I have I built my
attachment boot camp course take that it
will fix your attachment go from
insecure to secure change what you're
doing come to my coaching join my
attachment Circle Community let me talk
with you work with me come to my Live
Events anything learn that you can
change do not settle where you are and
have helplessness where you say well I'm
just going to be miserable for the rest
of my life and it's on my partner to
make me feel better because I have a
diagnosis of an attachment issue no fix
it then attract different people and be
more fully who you are supposed to be in
your relationships that's the answer
yeah self-knowing is not
self-justification is something that I'm
going to carry with me I think that's a
really lovely little summary there okay
next one most people in therapy are
there because the people in their life
who actually needed therapy refused to
get it how do you know this you the
person only comes in and you only speak
to them presumably the abusive uncle or
[__] father or bad baseball coach isn't
there how do you know
the number of times interestingly in my
practice through therapy and now as a
coach is people come in and I assess
where they're at and I say okay this
sounds like an environmental issue a lot
of my training was not just a Medical
Response it was an environmental focus
it was where is your environment
reshaping you that was what my current
my previous license was all about where
how has your environment causing this
issue so we would look at that and say
tell me about the people in your life
tell me how you're interacting with them
tell me their responses and then I would
say bring that person into therapy with
me now it's bring that person into
coaching with me and let me talk to them
and we talk and I interview them and I
look at them and I see how they act and
by and large it is that person who
actually really needs the help the one
who refused to come in because the one
who actually came in was the one trying
to work and make it better by and large
that is the case and especially when I
work with young people whose parents are
the ones who are the driving force and
teaching them the bad messages that's it
most men don't know how female
communication Works they provide
Solutions which is what they would want
when a woman wants validation when this
is pointed out most men assume it's
untrue because they'd hate to receive
only validation instead of a solution
and isn't that true have you ever had
that experience where a woman says talk
to me and you say what am I supposed to
talk to you about have you ever had that
experience Chris yeah of course
especially with younger younger Partners
you know in your early 20s I think when
everybody is poor at communicating
that's it's very common
why do women do this women do this
because to them communication is trust
it illustrates that you trust them it
illustrates you're willing to spend time
with them it illustrates you want them
to understand you so that they can be
more helpful to you in the future it
illustrates to them that you are
emotionally invested when you listen to
that when you share with them that's
what that tells them when you let them
share with you it tells them very much
the same that you are curious about
helping them you're curious about being
with them you are interested in them
you're invested in them you are willing
to spend your time on them and you like
your time with them when men stop and
try to throw out solutions they are
cutting to the end of the conversation
and saying I don't have time for you
that's what the woman is actually
hearing not here is a wonderful solution
that I wish someone had given me they
hear I don't have time for you take your
solution and get out of my face that is
what men are accidentally saying when
they number one shut them down Solutions
or number two they refuse to open up
about their day share about their
thoughts share about their difficulties
they're experiencing when they refuse to
share you are telling her I am not
interested in you I could replace you
with any woman out there that's so
interesting a failure of cross-sex mind
reading yet again yet again what are the
differences in male and female
communication then so why in your
opinion do so many couples struggle to
communicate effectively well why did we
evolve communication in the different
ways why did men develop one brain that
is solution focused and women develop a
brain that's relationship focused you go
back to the hunter-gatherers you go back
to 20 000 years ago before the Neolithic
Revolution right before we realized if
we eat seeds and poop them out that it
grows more seeds where we poop them out
so we should live there that we before
we learned that men had to go out and
hunt and survive and fight women stayed
at home and bonded and nurtured and
cared and that's where our communication
Styles really started coming out the guy
who was out in the field with the
mammoth saying hey John I hope you're
feeling okay I hope things are all right
you know if it's not too much trouble
maybe you could think about going over
there because there might someday be
like and by that time the mammoth has
already run you down and killed you and
you and John are now dead so those guys
were like let's get out of here go over
there go live over there with the women
because I don't want to hear it that's
out there it's hey you go over there
there's a mammoth stab it with a spear
I'll jump on its back that's the
communication we evolved is find me a
solution now I don't have much time and
I gotta get it done quick women other
way slower communication they were
around the whim the children teaching
guiding listening nurturing sharing of
resources sharing of time women
developed sharing men developed solving
if you look at the different
communication Styles even today we are
still living those same patterns
why then is it the case that men and
women can't communicate on where they
want to go for dinner
they can if if the man explains what he
is looking for so the more anxious a
woman is the more she is afraid of
disrupting the relationship a fully
secure woman is not as likely to have
that problem but any woman with any
level of anxiety is going to struggle
because he says where do you want to eat
and she doesn't think selfishly and say
I want to eat over here she says what
would he want to eat what's a good
answer for us what's a good experience
for us where did he want to eat last
time would he want to eat there again
well and then anxious women their brain
kicks in and says but if we pick wrong
he could be mad he could have a horrible
time it could even lead to us breaking
up I don't want to do that and they
cycle out like that and then they get
stressed out and then the other half of
women have a mental problem a mental
load problem where they've been
struggling with it and making decisions
all day and they're exhausted and say
just you make the decision you're of a
man you tell me what we're supposed to
do because there was resentful because
they feel overburdened and stressed out
and the guys sit there going just pick
just eats where do you want to go that's
why that fight is happening because he
doesn't see that happening under the
surface and she doesn't know how to
convey that to him either that's why men
and women will starve to death slowly
arguing about what they wanted to eat
for lunch last week one of my boys has
got a solution that he uses when he
wants to go somewhere his partner is a
the woman is pretty sort of decision
oriented in any case so it wouldn't be
an issue to get her to contribute where
she wanted to go so he has used
neuro-linguistic programming to trick
her into going to the place that he
wants to go to so what he says he
proposes the place that he wants to go
in the negative so he'll say listen I
with regards to dinner this evening
would you be opposed to going to
Cheesecake Factory
like I mean who's opposed to going to
Cheesecake Factory no one's opposed it's
like well look I'm not opposed to going
to Cheesecake Factory there's maybe
somewhere else well no no no if you're
not opposed my preference would be
Cheesecake Factory and given that you're
not opposed to it and this is my
preference
how about we go Cheesecake Factory uh
which I actually thinks of like a really
fantastic all those slightly
manipulative way to uh interesting
Cheesecake Factory it sounds like a
couple that needs to work a little bit
on uh balancing out but uh hey you know
what if it's working for them so far
they haven't killed each other then
power to them as much cheesecake as you
want okay next one that's right most
women with attachment issues ramp the
sex drive through the roof even more
than usual at the start of a
relationship and then nosedive the
moment it becomes long term and they
hate themselves for both sides of it I
made so many women angry with a comment
along the lines of this one on Instagram
where I posted that if she is just you
if all she thinks she has to offer in
the relationship is her body then she
really has nothing to offer in the
relationship and so many women got angry
at that because so many women that's all
they feel they have to offer it's an
endless Act of please don't leave me I
will do anything to make you like me and
that's all they think they have and then
they are just In Perpetual survival mode
so then after they've made you happy
happy happy happy they just sit and
collapse and then men complain women
today don't have any cooking skills
domestic skills they have nothing we ask
because those women are terrified and
they're just an endless survival mode so
they just try to make you happy and then
collapse until the next time they have
to make you happy that's unfortunately
how it goes
um why would the sex drive fall off a
cliff
after a while because it has built on
emotional intimacy and women who have
those attachment issues those
insecurities are incapable of receiving
that good love and reassurance even if
he's giving it so even if he is trying
to build an emotional connection with
her she will actually push it away and
do the one thing that would make her
feel safe and secure because it's the
one thing that makes her feel most
unsafe and unsecure that right there is
the problem those women actively reject
the very thing that would enhance their
relationships and their sex drive so a
woman a man who gets into a relationship
or a one-night stand or casual sex with
a woman who is very performative in the
bedroom in the first instance that's got
to be one of the Amber flags at least
for this kind of a personality I'm
guessing exactly if she well if she goes
to bed with you on the first date yes
it's a gigantic red flag uh or Amber
flag in that case yes it is it's massive
if she is able to build any kind of
barrier and say you know what I'm
looking for some level of commitment
before I will do these steps with you
and then she follows through on that and
then continues looking for addition
commitment that's where the healthy
women really are to be honest with you
do you not think that there's a case
where the
predisposition that women have to make
men wait to be more choosy with their
partners
can be
heavily deprogrammed by a wildly sex
positive culture that tells women that
true freedom is having a job like your
father and having sex like your brother
it's even that though is based on fear
because women don't really want that the
research shows that only two percent of
women prefer a hookup over a real
relationship 98 of women prefer a real
long-term relationship over any kind of
a hookup but they say that up to 80
percent of University women will have a
hookup it's that they are settling for
the little that they actually believe is
possible and the little that makes them
at least not feel as unsafe it's false
intimacy and false connection for the
sake of feeling like there's something
in their world that makes them feel
connected to a human being it is not
that they crave it is that they think
all they can get and everything else is
too terrifying to reach for that's very
sad why do you think that that's the
case why are they thinking like that
because so many of them didn't receive
the love they needed from their father
growing up and it's back to daddy issues
which so many people make fun of but so
many of them did not Bond fully and
connectedly with a fully embracing and
vibrant father who showed them what love
and cooperation and intimacy and trust
and conflict and conflict resolution and
cooperation is supposed to look like and
they are just petrified no one on this
Earth will ever really love them
okay next one some people actually
believe you must have sex with someone
before you marry them to make sure if
it's good sex and as if sexual behavior
is innate and not cultivated through
deep connection a communication and
sharing of needs these people want
physical intimacy without emotional
intimacy yeah it's it's an excuse not to
commit nobody who says have sex before
marriage otherwise it's going to turn
out bad no one like that ends up getting
into a very happy marriage because they
all they have done is emphasize the
overwhelming pleasure and it's just one
more reason not to have a loving
intimate relationship usually those
women are like what if he has a
three-inch penis with a Barb on the end
of it and I don't find out till my
wedding night something outrageous like
that that is just overwhelming
um that's one thing I hear all the time
and all the other women like yeah that
could totally happen no no no no the
extreme outlier so you have to bang your
way through 20 dudes so you can find one
who has a perfectly shaped penis yeah no
I don't think that is how our our human
species evolved to function like that
the other piece though is this is one
more excuse to not get married people
will do everything but get married
people will have five children and three
dogs and buy a house and move to another
country and give their partner one of
their kidneys but will not get married
because the concept of becoming
responsible to another human being and
being legally vulnerable in any way
shape or form terrifies them those are
the people that say you must have sex
before marriage because what if it's bad
that's not to say to just jump on the
back of the first point you made there
that's not to say that anybody that has
sex before they get married is
inherently going to be a bad marriage
partner it's the people that proselytize
about it to others that it's something
which you must do that that is another
quite dark Amber flag and yeah I I mean
the UK's ons data came back and for the
first time ever
51.4 percent of children are born
outside of marriage so this is to either
single mothers or outside of marriage or
a civil partnership so this is to either
single mothers or mothers that are just
cohabitating with an illegal agreement
or perhaps even not cohabitating
separately habitating but with no legal
agreement
um
a lot of avoidance going on here
massively massively very much fear very
much Terror this is why the divorce rate
is declining but it's declining because
fewer people are getting married it's
it's why the sex rate is declining
because people are so terrified of each
other they don't even want to have sex
anymore people are going to sit in their
home and watch porn or binge Netflix or
suck down energy drinks they're gonna
dopamine binge over and over and over
because their brains are so deficient on
every other hormone that there's a
neurotransmitter they're supposed to
have because they're we're not meant to
live in cold sterile little apartments
and little tiny cubicles where we don't
connect with other human beings we are
meant to be in big messy dirty hard
environments that challenge us and make
us bond with other human beings through
trials and through nurturing and through
sadness and through joy we are meant to
live messy lives and our lives are not
messy Enough Michael Easter wrote a
great book called The Comfort crisis
which is about this and talking about
challenges of uh excessive convenience
and it's really really not good and it's
so difficult to push back against
because convenience feels good and
comfort feels good the warmth of the
couch on a an evening time when it's
cold outside and you've had a hard day
at work compared with whatever the thing
is the difficult conversation with your
partner taking the dog out for another
work going to the gym like you said you
would spending time on Duolingo to learn
Spanish because it's the New Year's
resolution that you made for yourself
all of these things are difficult and
the
problem is that the Overton window of
difficulty has been constrained so much
that our lives are unbelievably
comfortable and it means that we are
ever less resilient when discomfort
comes a knocking and it's going to
happen you know unchosen suffering is
going to come and smash you in the face
whether you're ready for it or not and
the more fragile that you've made
yourself by never exposing yourself to
the outsides of this Overton window of
comfort the less capable you're going to
be of dealing with it absolutely you
must experience these things and one
more time as a child your brain decided
that if you were ever vulnerable and
exposed to other people you would die so
you're dealing with an ongoing fear of
death that tracks right in so not only
are you too comfortable but the brain
says hmm would I rather sit here and
jerk off to porn and drink this Mountain
Dew or would I rather have go go have a
conversation that could kill me no I
think I'm gonna stay right here that's
the difference that so many people are
experiencing is that level of dichotomy
and it's just it doesn't have to be that
way and it cannot remain that way tell
you what's interesting I had a
conversation with William Costello good
friend one of the number one in-cell
researchers in the world and we were
discussing this Advent of AI generated
images for only funds and chat GPT that
would potentially be able to give you
the virtual girlfriend experience
completely customized to your quirks and
fetishes and then we discussed about
what happens if we roll this down the
line and you get to VR and you have a
virtual reality world and then it's kind
of like uh her I think is the movie I
can't remember movie that's got maybe
Joaquin Phoenix and someone that's where
he has a virtual girlfriend one of the
things that William brought up which is
an odd white pill was you could imagine
a world in which VR technology is
sufficiently widespread and
sophisticated and avatars in a virtual
reality world are able to model male or
female preferences sufficiently
accurately that you will be able to for
the first time in human history have a
Sandbox to practice mating in to
practice
um discussing with somebody at a bar to
practice practice getting intimate with
somebody without being too pushy to
practice fully getting intimate with
someone so that and what it means is one
of the concerns we have at the moment
overcoming this approach anxiety the the
the the challenge of getting over the
initial approach hump is very high but
if you were you know a level 87 Master
dungeon master in like like girlfriend
VR or whatever
um you would have it would be one of the
first times that you can have a
realistic crossover from what's happened
in VR over into that and then imagine in
this world you know in in ten years time
instead of you making your coaching
courses online you're able to get some
VR programmer in you can give them
here's your five uh most healthy women
that you want to look for and here's the
five most red flag women here's the
avatars and then all right boys like you
know every single night you're going to
spend a bit of time in the VR World
practicing and then you go out to the
bar and you're just this super capable
dude I think I thought that was really
really exciting that was the best white
pill I've heard about VR for guys and
for women in basically forever imagine
if we sanitized to the birds it was a
pornographic but imagine if we made that
into a high school course that each each
person had to take of here's how you
approach another human being in a loving
healthy way that will actually lead to a
committed relationship here's what it's
going to look like you're gonna have to
go through all whole semester and by the
end of the semester you have to get this
other person this other dating simulator
whatever to marry you if that was at the
end of it imagine what we could
accomplish in our society by that point
because we'd all graduate with a degree
in being able to get someone to marry us
and that that in itself that would be
fascinating dude that's benevolent VR
that's where if we get it right if we
manage to interject into the current
sort of uh trajectory of what's going on
that would be great okay so you put out
a list of the dumbest mistakes that guys
make on the first three dates and I want
to go through these the first one was
they're way too shy and stick to surface
level talk
so many guys are trying to give the
woman a fun experience and that's not
what women who are looking for
commitment are looking for they're not
they're tired of the fun they are tired
of just having endless people dancing
for them that's not really what they
want they want substance but they're
afraid to tell you they want substance
give her your life mission give her your
purpose give show her who you are and
where you are going and invite her along
on that Journey that is what attracts
women but surely you also need to come
across as being fun you can't just do
the most boring thing in the world so
how do you balance these two
if you are talking about what is most
deeply passionate to you how could it
possibly not be fun yes if you're just
rambling on for six hours about your
stock portfolio or something like that
it's awful but if you're having an
intimate conversation with another human
being explaining that and then learning
her Mission learning her desires what
she's passionate about it should be fun
but not fun for the sake of fun it's not
masturbatory fun it is fun for a purpose
that drives education about the other
person what is the easiest way for a guy
to Broach going Beyond surface level
talk and into something a bit deeper
tell her stories that illuminate what
your life goals are that illuminate what
your values and principles are don't
tell her life stories that try to make
her impressed by who you are or make her
feel sorry for you or make her want to
jump on top of you tell her the life
stories that illuminate who you really
are as a man and where you are going and
that that right there will educate her
while also entertaining her what's the
difference between the two or could you
give us some an example yes so many men
default back to trying to explain what
they've purchased recently or they
default back to how amazing they are in
some way they try to tell stories that
pitch them as I'm better than my friends
or these are my exes this is why I left
them because I was better than them or
whatever it may be that you are trying
to elicit a certain feeling in the other
person that then makes them act a
certain way instead tell the stories
that educate them while also
entertaining them and say this is a
glimpse into Who I Really Am convenient
and inconvenient here is who I am and
here is what I'm trying to achieve those
are the pieces so you may say here is
let me tell you a story about my work
lately let me tell you a story about
this place where I volunteer let me tell
you a story about my family and you tell
that story to show her who you are
there will be a lot of women that are
listening so I would like to know if
whether you think that this is something
that guys that you go on dates with do
regularly or whether you would like them
to do it more the second one they go way
too hard with red pill and Pick Up
Artist tactics
so many guys are trying to rush through
and establish physical contact and
dominance as fast as possible and what
they're trying to do is mimic being in
love they're trying to do something
called love bombing they're trying to
make her feel wow he's really in love
with me and then it releases the same
oxytocin hormone in her that creates a
rush and makes her feel overwhelmed it's
love bombing and it is just fake and it
is not what she's actually looking for
insecure women will fall for it secure
women will shove you back and through
the door because they know what you're
trying to do and it's really
uncomfortable for them the only thing
you're going to do is Farm insecure
women which is why red pill and Pua guys
say hit on a hundred women a night and
one of them will sleep with you you are
trying to find someone who's so insecure
should lets you jump through her
boundaries and make her feel validated
one of the problems that a bunch of
friends had about 10 or 15 years ago
when the game came out first with Neil
Strauss was
they became very disenchanted with who
they were personally because they
created a Delta between the person that
their
uh evening partner was going to go home
with and the person that they really
were and that made them feel bad about
themselves they thought oh hang on so
this is how performative I have to be in
order to get a girl to go home with me
which then makes them both resent
themselves but even more so resent women
because they feel unlovable as who they
are despite the fact that they've never
shown who they are to the person that
they're talking to because that person
is inherently broken and unlovable but
that um positing an ideal version of you
or a Pua ideal version of you and
feeling the gap between where you are
and who that person is get made more of
the guys that did pick up black pill
than the guys that didn't go home with
girls
these are the guys who come into my
coaching practice with millions of
dollars in the bank and they sleep with
five different girls every week and they
say Adam I have never been more
miserable than I am right now these are
the guys who come in because they think
everything is about being fake that's
just like it goes back to Red Pill it
teaches you to be avoidant on purpose to
never find real love because Real Love
Is Impossible when you learn that that
is not true when you learn that you must
be who you are so that you can attract
someone who is attracted to you long
term that's the only way to build Puffs
and once you do that then you start
filtering for the right people next one
they play games like don't text her for
three days bro
game playing is just a way of saying I
don't trust you enough to connect with
you so I'm going to push your buttons
I'm going to manage you like a video
game and I'm going to play until I get a
win condition or until I get game over
and then I'm out of here and that's what
games are if you're playing games with
her and trying to read her mind and
trying to figure it out you've already
lost
we've got the other side of this as well
which is they're way too nice and overly
romantic
way too nice and overly romantic either
comes across as love bombing like you're
being fakes you're trying to make her
feel amazing to forget that she doesn't
actually love you yet so she'll sleep
with you or it comes across as being
eager to please Mom because you're
trying to please women the way you
pleased your mother growing up and you
don't know what women actually want from
you both are a fairly big turn off for
secure women the only people who respond
to that are avoidant women who are
looking for anxious men to snap up and
have sex with for a period of time and
then dump you and then just reconfirm
the red pill beliefs or women who are
really anxious and are ultimately
craving that approval from you and you
don't really want to connect with either
woman you want a woman who is secure and
stable who is going to give you a life
partnership Mark Manson's models says
that the number one turn off for women
is neediness what's your thoughts on
that
neediness is very different from having
needs neediness is childhood neediness
is saying I can't find Solutions I'm
going to lay here crying until someone
else solves my problem for me it is not
like most men say being a completely
immovable stone that never has a
weakness because women don't want that
either they want to see that you have
vulnerabilities and challenges that they
can help you with but they also want to
see you rising to the occasion and
solving those problems because they want
and respect a man who views Solutions
and approaches them and applies them
they assume she doesn't want to hear
from them again because she wasn't
explicitly throwing herself at him
so many guys who don't who navigate from
Red Pill into regular dating and say she
didn't try to sleep with me what's wrong
with me and they build validation based
on if she's trying to have sex with him
and women do this too if you don't
understand what real interest from a
securely attached person looks like
someone who's not rushing into the
relationship for validation if you don't
know what that looks like you think they
are uninterested or bored or boring and
you must recalibrate what actual
romantic interest looks like before you
can really pursue a healthy relationship
they try to rush to sex
rushing to sex is just going to muddy
the waters number one it's going to
flood you with feelings and her with
feelings that are not actually what's
happening it's going to convince you
that you love each other even when you
don't you don't even know each other yet
and it's going to turn off any women
that you actually would want to build a
long-term relationship with I wouldn't
uh I really do would be very interested
to get some more data around
um attachment Styles and psychological
stability correlated with whether women
have sex either on the first date or or
how many dates it would be and this
would need to be revealed rather than
stated preferences because there's a
pretty big observer effect here to
perhaps give a a different answer to the
one that actually happens
I would be very interested I I'm pretty
fascinated by the the ability of modern
culture especially a very sex positive
modern culture to perhaps reprogram or
deprogram some felt innate
predispositions that women do have when
it comes to how long they feel like they
should wait you know because if you're
around unless you come from a
particularly traditional very strong uh
values household if you are a girl that
is around a bunch of other girls and all
of those girls have a lot of casual sex
regardless of your own personality
disposition and your own values it's
going to be very difficult to not have
that impact to the way that you see
relationships
well especially if you look at it and
she says I have very little to offer
here is a really awesome man all the
other women on Earth are going to give
him sex instantly why on Earth would he
stay with me if I don't I'm gonna have
to let him do whatever he wants so that
I can try to keep him to be competitive
in the marketplace of pulling in a good
man that's a lot of women women set the
price of sex for each other and a lot of
women are racing toward the bottom
they share the wrong type of stories Mrs
man goes right back to what we talked
about is share the stories about your
family share the stories that illuminate
your good friendships share the stories
about your accomplishments without being
a pompous [__] about it share the
stories that show her what you're
building not just what you've
accomplished in the past but what you're
building for the future share the
stories about your business that tells
you you have a business share the
stories about your best friends it tells
you you have best friends stereo share
your stories about your best friends and
how they are moral people it tells her
you spend time around moral people tell
her stories about your mother or your
sister or your family that tells her
that you value those people and you will
continue to be around them and it tells
her what you do when you're in
relationships tell her those stories
rather than stories that make her think
that you are a complete stud in the
bedroom and you have a million dollars
in the bank that's not what a stable
woman's looking for final one they don't
mention commitment at all
women are petrified Dimension commitment
men are petrified Dimension commitment
most people want it everyone's afraid to
talk about it because they think they
will be the psycho in the room what I
tell people is through my three date
method you should be dating through the
first three dates so that you can talk
about becoming an exclusive couple by
the third date and this is the system
that actually works for people who are
moving through with good secure
attachment three dates is all you really
need to build an at least exclusive
relationship I'm not talking get married
yet but to know that the other person is
the right person for you three dates and
then you begin really testing for deeper
commitment do you think that it's more
difficult in the modern world for men or
women to talk about commitment early on
[Applause]
I think that both are equally terrified
of it and I think that women are utterly
afraid of it because they think they are
never allowed to speak about it I have
women who come into my live events on
Tick Tock for example and they say Adam
it's been eight years do you think he's
ever going to think about marrying me
say have you ever asked them well
anytime I've kind of brought up the idea
he's broken up with me for about six
weeks and then gets back together with
me and has slept with three other women
so I've learned never to even mention
commitment hmm okay most women will will
wait around for eight years on the idea
of maybe getting married someday so I
would say that Society definitely is
harder on women who want commitment but
if women were more open about what they
wanted they would filter out the men who
don't want it and they would attract to
the men who absolutely do want it Adam
Lane Smith ladies and gentlemen mate I
absolutely love you I love your work I
think your Twitter's fantastic I'm
really really enjoying seeing you
flutteration all the different courses
and books that you're releasing if
people are interested in what we've gone
through today and they want to go deeper
where should they go so I have my
website adamlanesmith.com I've got my
attachment boot course boot camp course
on there that guides you through the 10
steps of fixing your attachment and
building amazing relationships I've got
my personal coaching on there that I can
work with you and I am on Twitter at the
brometheus I'm on YouTube at Adam Lane
Smith I'm also on Instagram at
attachment Adam and I'm on Tick Tock at
attachment bro you can find me anywhere
on the internet and now on Facebook
interestingly of all places I blew up in
about one month I went from 300
followers to almost 10 000 followers
based on just a couple of things I
posted on there so people are hungry for
this good information I'm happy to help
dude I appreciate you thank you for the
day thank you man what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to send subscribe
peace
me
ant